no dragon egg it's really important I am
Amelia Clark and I play Daenerys
Stormborn Targaryen aka Khaleesi
I mean I could do the whole title but
I'm not gonna generis is she's with her
brother
I'm Viserys their title was taken from
them they were used up and so the people
who took their family threatened the
Iron Throne are now looking for any
remaining members of that family to try
and kill off any chance that someone
could come back spoiler and try again
that's right that person being me my
brother's plan to take back the Iron
Throne was to try and marry me off to a
warlord who has an army my brother
thinks as is kind of unwritten in law
you marry off to appropriate people you
have money armies land whatever once
it's in the family it's yours I know how
to play a man like Drogo I give him a
queen and he gives me an army but Khal
Drogo
he doesn't understand he's not that kind
of guy
at my wedding I meet Sir Jorah are you
from my country I served your father for
many years got to be good I hope to
always serve the rightful king and the
dragon eggs they're given as a
ritualistic gift our wedding night is a
make-or-break of her as a human being
that relationship is the key to Daenerys
as a character
really because without Khal Drogo you
wouldn't have the Daenerys that you see
now she gives the funeral for her
husband and for whatever reason she
wants to be with him and the worst thing
that can happen is that she dies with
her husband so what's there to lose
she's looked into the flames and some
five she's given birth technically to
three dragons she's at home it's all
good got one person I got to get rid of
Cersei Lannister the end John who now I
assume my lord you're here to bend the
knee I am NOT then why are you here
because I need your help and you need
mine he needs heard the dragonglass that
is underneath the family seat because of
some silly idea that there's an army of
the Dead coming they fought together
against their common enemy we need to do
the same if we're gonna survive I will
fight for the north when you bend the
knee
Daenerys was this entire time thinking
that also yet to worry about with Cersei
Lannister now through John Snow
because she learns that she has to worry
about the undead and they can cocked a
plan what they're going to do is they're
going to go and capture one and bring it
to King's Landing show it to Cersei and
to everyone who was waging this war to
say we need to banded together and we
need to fight this we need to fight this
together because it doesn't matter who's
gonna be sitting on the Iron Throne
there won't be one
if we don't nuke these guys so she sends
her boys on this mission and they don't
make a success of it
get a ribbon to Daenerys tell her what's
happened she hears about this and so I
do as I do I get on my dragon much
Rotarians just like and I go and save
the day
in doing it my dragons kills not only is
this a source of her power not oh is
this a source of our identity this is
her child and losing that is akin to
losing everything we are a group of
people who do not like one another the
first time in seven years you've seen
all of these characters together we have
something to show you we all agree that
this is where the battle is this is what
we need to fight the darkness is coming
for us all we'll face it together and
when the Great War is over perhaps
you'll remember I chose to help don't
help this season there's been an
undercurrent of Romans blossom Donny and
John take it to the next level in one
night to run one vote ahead for
Winterfell heading for season eight
hey everybody is Charlie I got a lot of
requests to do the Daenerys Game of
Thrones Season 8 promo
she spends a lot of time talking about
Jon Snow which is why I clip this down
to mostly the season 7 season 8 stuff
she talks about there a couple really
important things about her origin story
that she talks about so I tried to add
those too so we'll put it on to context
because there's a lot that she and Jon
Snow share in comment that we haven't
really talked about I don't think in any
of the videos that I've done before but
it's the holidays there's a new round of
that Song of Ice and Fire book giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video there are a couple of funny things
in this too like Emilia Clarke just
being funny while talking about Daenerys
Targaryen in a really important way like
obviously all the Game of Thrones stuff
is very serious but she does manage to
work a couple of jokes in there she
stops just short of calling it the sex
boat that would actually been great but
that was more of a fan thing that we
were calling it before the actual finale
so that was just one of the best memes
to come out of season 7 one of the more
important things that she talks about
when she's talking about Daenerys as
origins as a character that also makes
her very similar to Jon Snow in certain
respects not just the fact that they're
related by blood we'll be spending a lot
of time talking about that during the
season eight episodes when all the other
characters start to find out about that
- because clearly it's gonna be a big
point of drama between the characters
for at least a couple episodes but when
she talks about how she's getting ready
to burn caldron
in her baby Rae go in that funeral pyre
she walks into the fire - trying to kill
herself so that she can die with them it
didn't work she wound up hatching her
dragons because of all the blood magic
in play and she became known as Daenerys
unburnt henceforth but they both
sacrificed their lives even though Jon
Snow
technically did not go willingly that
first time it was the traitorous
brothers of the Nights Watch F Olly they
sort of called back to it again when
she's questioning him in this funny
moment about something that she heard
about him taking knives to the heart for
the cause it seems like just for a
minute like he might actually reveal the
truth of dying and coming back to life
before they're interrupted by Sir Jorah
but even if she doesn't totally
understand what happened to him or even
how she actually hatched her dragon eggs
she saw most of his scars during episode
6 so I think she implicitly absorbs some
of the things that he's endured so she
kind of gets it and any scars that she
didn't see during episode 6 she
definitely saw during episodes
the sex boat but if he didn't pick up on
it there was a little bit of
foreshadowing for season 8 when she's
talking about some of the most important
aspects of Denise's character she has a
couple superpowers her dragons and she
is Daenerys unburnt even though
technically it doesn't work that way in
the books what the TV show has done is
it's turned that into a regular thing
for her and she cannot be burnt by fire
by any means although we haven't tested
that with wildfire yet the difference in
the books is is that she was under 20
was hatching her dragons because special
blood magic was invoked by Miri Master
she can't do it on command anytime she
wants but her other superpower and this
is a major moment of foreshadowing for
season eight is that she loses
everything at every turn and somehow is
able to carry on and move forward that's
her big thing she loses everything but
find some way to move forward so at the
beginning of the story she loses her
home when she's forced to marry Khal
Drogo then she loses her only family
that she knows of at the time because
she doesn't know about Jon Snow being
related to her when Khal Drogo anoints
Viserys with his golden crown she loses
her child Rago then Khal Drogo she loses
her dragons in Qarth she almost loses
drogon again in a stupor when one of the
dragons is the only payment crassness
will except for the legions of unsullied
warriors she needs to by she loses sir
Jorah when she learns about his
treachery then she loses Barristan Selmy
to the sons of the harpy she loses
drogon again when she escapes the sons
of the harpy flying out a dazz nak spit
and is captured by Khal jhaqo and the
other cows and drogon it's just so laid
out that he has to stay there she winds
up losing Daario in Mereen when she
finally has to sail back to Westeros for
the Iron Throne then obviously during
season seven she loses her dragon
Viserion and almost loses Jon Snow so
one of the few things that you can set
your watch on every single season and in
every book from A Song of Ice and Fire
is that Daenerys loses something major
that she holds dear at every turn so big
question is what is she going to lose
during season eight that she holds dear
remember she's closer than ever to Jon
Snow at the beginning of season eight
there were several clues in scenes
during season seven that implied she
will become or is already pregnant with
Jon Snow's baby at the beginning of
season
she still has two of her dragons she has
Tyrion and Serge Ora who probably the
two people she's closest to I would say
she's closer to Serge Ora than she is to
Tyrion they have a bit of a weird
relationship during season seven but all
those people all those things she could
potentially lose at some point during
season eight let me know what you think
it's actually going to be because I mean
it's just implied that so many people
are gonna die during season eight the
whole idea being she loses something big
every single season
it'll probably wind up being some or
most of the people she's closest to
including her dragons drogon and regal
we're probably gonna get that next big
trailer sometime towards the end of
January they usually work in footage
from later in the seasons too so it'll
be a little easier to theory craft once
we start seeing those but post all your
early theories in the comments below
there's a whole bunch more Game of
Thrones Season 8 promos that they
release I'll try to do videos for
everything in the next couple of weeks
but leave your requests in the comments
below I'm also gonna be traveling this
weekend so I'll try to keep my video
schedule as much as possible just look
for video updates and those top pinned
comments on the videos that I post and
on my Twitter and my facebook accounts
congratulations Jonathan headland you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
you can click here to rewatch that Jon
Snow season 8 promo
and you can click here for all the other
Game of Thrones season 8 promos that I
posted thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome and Happy
Holidays